voiture
[applaudissements]
[musique]
Je n'aime pas vraiment ça, mais
Tout ce qui devient beau rend l'école belle
Ouais
[musique]
dj ren
Ouais ouais ouais
dieu
brigade des stupéfiants
moi
[musique]
reebok
L'un est le temps de nettoyage dans le cadre des activités éducatives de l'école.
Positionné pour ne jamais manquer cet anniversaire
[musique]
[applaudissements]
Je n'utilise aucun centre
[musique]
le goudron
[applaudissements]
[musique]
C'était un enfant noir, n'est-ce pas ?
Eh bien, tout le monde sera beau, mais je ne peux pas faire ça
si absolument
Oh oh oh
[musique]
[applaudissements]
moi
e7a
[applaudissements]
[musique]
Ils m'aident pour tout, y compris le nettoyage de l'autel bouddhiste, donc je me sens vraiment comme un membre de la famille.
je pense que ça joue un rôle